oh yeah how I instantly turn into this
person when I put this off today we are
guessing the most expensive and the
least expensive engagement ring the most
experience I have with an engagement
ring with you're just having princess
cut yes world and settings the cut the
color carat the bigger the diamond the
more expensive I think we're gonna kill
I feel pretty good about it yeah I don't
know if I'll get any right so I feel
like this is a trap already I'm not
gonna be fooled by that's the one at a
time oh no I'm so excited so this one
looks more vintage yeah the diamond is
final
yeah the heart also a little cheesy
they're a telltale sign to me
they cheapen it definitely on the lower
half of the scale here now it's time for
the daintiest little diamond of them all
and look at that setting it's very
beautiful handmade maybe maybe she's
tricked us and the smallest stone is the
most expensive it's I think they're all
no per Nicky almost interesting Oh
obviously this one's the biggest so I'm
gonna try it on maybe this is just a
really good - oh [ __ ]
that's like a doorknob body is gleaming
it's cleanin although what is it
gleaming too much that's a very big rock
it's not real this one feels a little
fake to me
maybe if it's real quick-like oh hey
Josh Wow no this is not a real diamond
yeah like right away actually this right
away you could tell I don't want to take
this off you just did BAM
I think this one's most most extreme
mm-hmm oh I thought it was
now we have to now how comes the judge
princess sparkles is the most expensive
still classy princess her most expense
dead grandma's ring second most
expensive I'm playing a rich fancy woman
in a movie police expect okay so this
our final arrangement this is that I
think we're ready if you're gonna spend
like you know this much money on a ring
like I think it's just a part of your
duty to make sure that you know it comes
from like a good place that's worth it
that's that's how you buy ring right
there and like only a little bit
disappointed in myself at how excited I
got by all these shiny finger but you
know what that's okay I need to like
leave this here or also if my girlfriend
is watching this not yet but soon
[Music]